We all learned it in school: when it comes
to sex and gender women have two X chromosomes
and men have XY and that’s all there is
right?
Is anything that simple on this show?
Hello Everyone, Crystal here with DNews.
Science has known for a while that it is possible
for humans to be born with more or less than
two sex chromosomes.
These unusual combinations are rare in the
human population and in most cases are not
something you inherit from your parents, but
from an error during meiosis leading to an
inappropriate number of sex chromosomes in
the human gametes.
(yes, yes, … think back to high school biology
…) Usually mature eggs and sperm carry only
one sex chromosome, in the case of sperm either
an X or a Y.
When exceptions to this rule occur, it leads
to chromosomal abnormalities.
For instance, Turner’s syndrome occurs in
individuals who carry only one sex chromosome.
An X.
These individuals express the physical characteristics
of a human female but they are frequently
unable to have children and have a lower life
expectancy because that single X chromosome
is doing the work of two and the information
contained on that one X is less robust.
Often, pregnancies of Turner’s syndrome
babies do not make it to delivery.
Super females are the opposite, they have
an extra X.
There is usually no distinguishable difference
to the naked eye between those with triple
X and the rest of the female population.
but some studies based on small samples have
correlated exceptional height, learning disabilities,
and weak muscle tone to triple X individuals,
Similar abnormalities involving the Y chromosome
are also possible.
Although a Y-only permutation is fatal, combinations
such as XXY, XYY, XXYY and others do also
occur with variable frequency.
These individuals express male traits and
secondary sex characteristics due to the presence
of the SRY gene carried on the Y chromosome.
But what happens when that gene migrates to
another chromosome?
Can it do that?
Can an X chromosome express the gene that
makes male parts?
Well, science says actually yes!
Recent studies including one performed at
Arizona State University have shown that sex
chromosomes, like our other 22 pairs of chromosomes,
experience recombination.
All you really need to know about genetic
recombination is that while making sperm and
eggs our bodies replicate our chromosomal
DNA and then sort single copies of those physical
records of genetic information into eggs or
sperm that carry half of the set of instructions
needed for a healthy human including a single
sex chromosome and X or a Y.
When the copying process occurs, near identical
chromosomal pairs are smushed together in
a way that they can become tangled, and sometimes
identical parts of those chromosomes can get
shifted around from one to the other.
This tangled mixing is called recombination
and errors in this process are a contributing
factor to genetic variation and evolution.
But wait! you say, sex chromosomes are not
identical and therefore don’t have similar
gene sequences to tangle together and recombine.
Well actually they do.
Only the very ends of the X and Y chromosomes
contain enough similarity to stick together
and swap genes during meiosis.
But that is enough similarity to get the SRY
gene tangled up in the process.
Gene migration is not uncommon, we see it
frequently in evolution.
But when the gene responsible for the “male”
phenotype ends up on the chromosome responsible
for a “female” phenotype things get complicated.
This condition, called XX male or de la Chapelle
syndrome is relatively rare, occurring in
something like 5 in every 100,000 individuals.
The individuals carry the female XX chromosomal
signature but they develop like men, although
their testes are small and they are usually
sterile.
XX male syndrome has been identified since
the 1970’s but it’s only now that we are
starting to understand how the conditions
occurs.
What we can learn from this is that while
the sex chromosomes we carry do determine
a lot of our outward appearance and reproductive
characteristics, it is frustratingly not always
that simple and chromosomal composition is
not the last word in gender phenotype.
The past couple weeks on DNews and on our
spinoff show TestTube Plus, we’ve talked
a lot about sex and gender.
If you want to hear another take on the subject,
check out this video from our good friends
at Wisecrack.
They recently uploaded an episode of 8-Bit
Philosophy called “Is Gender Real?”
Again, it’s a great video, and we’re huge
fans of their channel, so make sure to subscribe.
If you’re on mobile, click the first link
in the description to watch.